I'm really excited to introduce
some more into lamb today.
She is here to discuss
your personal brand,
why it's important and what you
can do with it as some more.
The lamb is the founder of some
more insulin coaching as a coach,
counselor and lawyer some more in
provides a holistic approach to coaching
professionals, recent graduates and
students including women, people of Color,
and first generation professionals.
She has worked with over 1000
clients to assess their career goals,
develop effective job search strategies,
and manage their professional development.
She's committed to and
involved in diversity and
inclusion initiatives and is a
frequent featured speaker and moderator
at professional associations on hot
topics such as managing cultural code,
switching,
supporting first generation professionals,
sponsoring women of color and
developing leadership skills.
She has provided pro bono legal
services helping refugees,
children and elderly dependents and Pro
Bono career coaching services for first
generation professionals,
women of color and other diverse groups.
Let's join in welcoming some
more insulin to the stage.
Raise your hand if you
wake up feeling every day.
I can't wait to be my awesome self at work
here.
A lot of chuckles. No, raise your
hand if you want a wake, a feeling.
I can't wait to be my authentic
self at work. Awesome.
I've got everybody on there.
Welcome to authentically you taking
charge of your personal brand.
And before we dive into the program,
I want to take a moment to thank a
few people who made this happen. Uh,
neelay Mitchell, Kelsey bunch or an
Emily sorts for making this happen.
I know you guys are really busy.
Um,
and the fact that you're
taking this initiative to put
this together means a lot.
So if you guys can stand up, um, and if
we can just give them a round of applause
for their hard work.
I'm going to also want to thank
Google for providing this.
I think it's amazing that a company as
great as Google that's known to be one of
the greatest employers,
it's still continuing to invest in its
employees by providing a space and the
resources to make this happen.
So we can just give uncle Google
a big round of applause too.
And I also want to take the time to
acknowledge each and every one of you for
coming live and also, um, uh,
connecting via live stream.
I know all of you are incredibly busy.
I was just hearing about your
long commutes for some of you. Um,
and you could be out there taking pictures
with the I bought or going to the gym.
And the fact that you're here says a lot
about you and your commitment to your
career.
So a big round of applause for you.
Um, I don't want to take this opportunity
to do something that I think we often
don't do, especially for people who
are high performers like yourself.
That's the reason why you're
at a organization like Google.
So I want you to trust me with this.
If you can raise your hands really
wide and while you're added,
try not to talk to person on the right
or left and just to give yourself a big
hug and say, I'm so awesome. I couldn't
hear you. Let's do together again.
One more time. One, two,
three. I am so awesome.
Yeah. And that's just a great reminder
for yourself. I love seeing the smile.
It's just that can give
you so much energy. I think
sometimes we're in Britain,
the busier doing and getting things done,
you forget to acknowledge how
amazing you are and how far you come.
So if you just have this practice once
a day, maybe first thing in the morning,
that'll really help jumpstart your day.
So when I started my career,
um,
I struggled very much in my career.
I had this mentality that I have to put
my head down and work really hard and be
humble and not bother anybody because
everybody's really busy who can relate to
this. Ah, it was like everybody in
the room, everybody is really busy.
And I was the first in my family to go
to college and to go to professional
school. They didn't really have anybody
I could talk to to say like, Hey,
I'm running into this issue.
How can I solve that?
So I became known for being really
reliable, really dependable.
And that was great because I got a lot of
good work. How many can relate to that?
That the reward of good work is more work.
It's like everybody in this room,
they're like, yeah, that happens. Um,
but on the flip side,
what was not so great about having that
reputation was that on Fridays at 9:00
PM when there was an urgent project,
guess who got to call me?
And I'm assuming a lot of you are
also in that shoes as well, right?
Where you're the ones who are known to
be reliable and so you're getting this
call.
And so what happens is it creates a really
frustrating environment where you're
feeling tired and overworked
and underappreciated
because people are so busy,
they forget to thank you or to really
acknowledge you for your contributions.
And at the same time,
what I saw is that when it came
time for raises and promotions,
I wasn't necessarily getting the
best raises, their best promotions.
And a big part of that was
because I kept my head down.
It didn't talk to anybody and I
didn't want to bother anybody.
So nobody knew that I was doing
anything right. Other than that,
I was getting things done
when they needed it done. Um,
and so I found myself in a place where I
was really frustrated and exhausted and
just really wondering what I
was going to do in my career.
How many of you at some point of
your career can relate to that?
It's like almost everybody in here.
Um,
and it wasn't until I worked with a
leadership coach where she helped me to
question my assumptions and my values
and what it meant to be humble,
what it meant to be authentic and
what it meant to be a hard worker.
And then to devise some key strategies
where I made some small changes in the
way you interact with people,
that had a huge impact that I was able
to see my life and my career transform.
And I was so inspired by the work that
she was able to do with me and that
inspired me to become a coach.
And now I have the privilege of being
able to help my clients go from being
stuck or frustrated or waking up with
dread or maybe feeling a little bored at
work to go from that space to being at
a place where they're getting that dream
job that they want to go into
that space where they wake up,
excited to go to work and they're getting
the promotions and the raises that
they so worked hard for and deserve
and most importantly to be happy.
And I really excited to be here to
share those strategies with you.
We have a short now 45 minutes together,
cause I know we started
a little a little late,
so I'm going to give you my best stuff,
but I also know that we won't
be able to cover everything.
I will try to reserve a little bit of
time afterwards for questions and then
we'll hang out afterwards if you have
questions that you don't want to ask in
the audience and one as privately. Um,
and if you have questions beyond that,
feel free to always email me at
some more and add some more insulin.
coaching.com I do read every
email that comes through. Um,
so what we're going to cover today
is what is your personal brand?
Why does your personal brand matter?
How does authenticity fit
with their personal brand?
And then with all that information,
what do you want to do
without personal brand?
Okay.
So what is a personal brand?
Anybody recognize who that is?
Yeah.
Yeah. Somebody raised their hand. Awesome.
Who is that person? Oh, Bruh. Yes.
Everybody recognizes Oprah. So when
you see Oprah, her picture right here,
her name, what are some words
that you associate with her?
Success. What else? Confident.
What was that?
Yeah, she's loved. Yes, she's loved.
So what did the con consistent theme that
you're hearing in the words are being
described to Oprah? Would you say
it's positive, negative, or neutral?
Awesome.
Positive. Oprah has a very strong personal
brand. And if you know her backstory,
she started from very humble beginnings,
right?
But she had a strong vision about
who she was and what she stands for,
and now she's been able to build this
amazing empire where in a moment's notice,
she can put you on her book club list
and go from an unknown author to be a New
York Times bestseller overnight. Now
some of you might say, well that's cool,
but that's Oprah. What does that
have to do with me? Similarly,
in your own career,
if you have a strong personal brand,
you can really have the ability to make
things happen and to help accelerate
your career. Or if you have a negative
association with their brand, guess what?
That can also prevent you from being able
to be promoted or being able to get to
work on projects that you might want
to have or even be able to have good
relationships with your coworkers.
It's not the value of a brand.
And I want to bring up an example
of one of my recent clients. Um, my,
one of my recent clients
that I worked with,
it's an attorney who works
at a tech company. How many
attorneys are in the room?
I got like,
like one person in the back,
any engineers in the room, ah,
go like all engineers 11,
it's going to be like the fight
battle between engineers and lawyers.
So a common story that hear from my
engineering clients is I hate talking to
those lawyers who can relate
to that. Like everybody, right?
There are roadblocks [inaudible] they
don't understand the technology and it's
really a waste of time.
Um,
so that's a common response to
hear from my engineering clients.
And then on the other,
countable to hear from my lawyer
clients as those engineers,
they're really smart. They're so
brilliant, they make amazing products,
but they have no clue how they're
screwing our company for millions and
bazillions of dollars because they will
ever talk to us when they're doing these
licensing deals or they won't
patent these projects. Right. Um,
and so this is a common conversation
that goes on between these two clients.
It's funny because I get to sit behind
closed doors with them and I'm like, wow,
this comes up almost
every single instance.
And so what happens is there's a cat and
mouse game where, uh, issue comes up,
lawyer calls, engineer, engineer, avoids
lawyer. And that loop kind of goes on,
creates a very frustrating situation
and we have basically zero productivity.
And in fact,
what I argue is negative productivity
because who would be frustrated in that?
How many of you would be frustrated
with that? It's like I see everybody,
almost everybody's hands up. Yes.
It's a frustrating situation.
So what you end up with is energy where
you're spending a lot of time being
frustrated with each other and not a lot
gets done and then something big might
go wrong because you're not communicating
and there's a communication breakdown.
So this particular client went in knowing
that this is something that typically
happens. And so what we'd devise in terms
of a strategy for him was instead of
approaching the engineer's only
when there was a problem, uh,
with the legal issues to actually
go and get to know the engineers.
So this lawyer went to a
lot of the brainstorms. Um,
sometimes he understood what's going on.
Sometimes we were like,
I don't know what this is,
but he made friends when he was there.
And what he would do with invite these
engineers to go to coffees or to go to
lunches.
And through this process,
what he was able to do is ask
them about their lives, you know,
actually care about them as a human being.
How about that rate?
And then ask them like, what are you
working on? What's going on there?
And point blank say,
what can I as a lawyer and our
legal team do to support you in,
to better communicate with you because
we're really here to partner with you and
we really want to help you.
Um, and through that process
and through consistent,
and this is a key consistent interactions
and this way he was able to develop a
really strong relationship with them.
And so instead,
now when he calls the engineers,
they actually pick up his phone call and
instead of being seen as a roadblock or
he's actually seen as a true partner.
Um,
and what's also really interesting is
that now the engineer's how problems they
actually call him and say like,
Hey, are running into this issue.
Do you think you can give us a hand?
And so through those positive
associations with his personal brand,
he was able to transform it from a
negative association of being a negative
roadblocks, right? To being somebody
who's positive and a true partnership. Um,
and so he's able to in
his day to day life,
decreased frustration and increased
productivity and have more time to be able
to, to rebel in the successes that he
has. And how does that benefit has career,
has supervisors now know him as
somebody who is a problem solver,
who can connect with others?
And so he becomes a goto person when
the legal team needs to work with
engineering team and you can see
that it's a win win for everybody.
So that's pretty amazing, right?
The power of your personal brand.
Um, so what I love for us to do
right now is to do an exercise. Um,
and in this exercise,
often what people forget to think about
is how our perceptions of what's going
on actually impacts our interaction.
So what I want you to do is to trust me,
is to close your eyes. I make sure
nobody pokes you from the side.
And if somebody does, I'll
go and hit the hand. Um,
and so to think of some colleagues
that you have that you work with,
either in your group or
outside of your group,
and then to pick one person in mind,
and if that person had to describe
you using three adjectives,
what are the three adjectives
that's coming to mind?
Yeah.
And I want you to sit with
those adjectives for the
next five to 10 seconds,
a little uncomfortable,
but I want you to feel what that feels
like when you hear those adjectives about
yourself.
Now I want you to open your
eyes and on your handout,
write down what those three
adjectives are in the section.
That's what is your personal brand.
So what we're going to do
now as partner activity, um,
I want you to find a partner,
a and a final partner.
Hopefully somebody you don't
talk to regularly because the,
the purpose of these types
of conversations is really
to meet somebody else as
well. Right? So find a
partner. Go ahead and pair up.
If you're on the right side,
my right side,
you'll be partner a if you're partner
a can you raise your hand? Okay.
And then if you're on the left side,
you'll be partner B.
And if you were doing front and back,
the person in front will be a,
and the person in back, we'll
be beat. Okay. So if your ace,
can you raise your hand?
Okay. So A's in this exercise,
what we're going to do is you're
gonna get a chance to, to,
to tell your partner what
the three adjectives are and
what feelings came up for
you as you were thinking
about these adjectives. And B,
what you're going to do is
practice active listening.
What that means is you don't get to talk,
you don't get to ask questions,
you actually don't even get to make noise.
You can nod your head.
But the idea is to really listen.
And if there is an awkward silence,
sit in that awkwardness, but allow a to
really describe what's going on for them.
Okay.
So you're two minutes starts now.
Felt a lot of energy and positivity
and saw a lot of smiles. That's good.
So now be, you did such an
awesome job being a listener.
Guess what? It's your turn to
get to share. And a likewise,
please sit in silence and let the other
person just express their feelings.
And if there's awkwardness in the silence,
it's okay. Just let them keep going.
Okay.
So you're two minutes be starts now.
Yeah.
Wow.
So it sounds like there was a lot of
energy and enthusiasm and sharing.
Um, and what I love to hear
is what came up for you.
What were some of the adjectives?
How did it feel to actually share what,
what those agitated,
I just made you feel and what was
it like to be on the listening side?
Do you mind sharing what those two are?
Awesome.
You came back.
Okay. Taking initiative and being very
helpful. So very positive associations.
And when you thought about that about
yourself, how did that make you feel?
All right.
All right. Okay. He's like, um,
that's actually a common experience that
I did is a lot of people often don't
take time to really think about the
assumptions that they make about other
people and how those people
are perceiving them. Um,
and often the assumptions that we think
that other people are making about us
often or not as positive as what those
other people might be thinking because we
tend to be our worst critics. Um, I
love to hear a couple more shares.
Awesome.
Okay.
So you thought it was interesting that
you had a more positive association of
yourself and your partner had
a more negative association.
Maybe we maybe more self
aware or grilling. Yeah.
More self aware of more
critical. What, what,
what was it that you found
interesting about it?
Yeah. Yeah. Um, and you know, here's,
here's why these associations
are really important.
It's that if you have a
positive perception that
somebody else thinks you're um,
you know, a good person or easy to
work with, when you see that person,
are you more likely to engage with
that? Thumbs up? Yes. Thumbs down, no.
Mostly thumbs up. Yes.
Yeah. Now on the flip side,
if you're like your partner where
you might think like, oh, I don't,
I don't think that person really likes me.
Or it was difficult to work with that
person. When you see that person,
are you going to want to engage with them?
No.
So this is the power of perception about
your own personal brand and this is
often a critical piece that people don't
think about is what are the assumptions
that are underlying that is impacting
our interactions with others.
And um,
I'll share a really good example of this
is one of my clients I worked with her
and she's really amazing across the board
with her peers and her sub ordinance.
She's seen as somebody who's really
amazing, wonderful to work with.
How many of you know amazing colleagues
like that? It's like everybody,
it's googled course. You've got to
know at least one person like that. Um,
but the thing is that she was being passed
up for promotions and raises all the
time. We were like, Huh, that's odd. Like
why are you being patched up all the time?
I don't get this.
Like you were really fantastic.
And what we uncover was that she never
talked to her boss and the only time she
talked to her boss was one,
there was a crisis or something urgent.
Does that sound familiar to everybody?
You can get a lot of head nods like, yeah.
Okay.
So now I want you to imagine if you were
her boss and you saw her trotting down
the hallway, hey boss, or you
don't want to talk to her? No,
because she's basically the
crisis problem person, right?
So you've just had this very negative
association with her and she also has this
very negative association with her boss
of light. He's always frustrated with me.
So when she goes in, she's not her
awesome, authentic self. Right?
Because her awesome authentic
self is somebody who's social.
He gets along with people
who wants to be helper.
But when she goes to her boss because
you have this association that he finds
her annoying or she's disrupting him
or bother him, she just freezes up.
And the only thing she goes to him and
is like, Hey, we have this problem.
Can we solve it? It's not making
for a really good relationship.
I see a lot of labs out there like look
at people like yeah, that's, that happens.
Yeah. And it's easy to imagine that
happening because we're all so busy.
So what I would challenge you to do, um,
and in what we did with our client was,
hey, when you're having your one
on one meetings with your boss,
which happened every two weeks for her,
it's to not only go in and be like, hey,
here are the five problems.
What are we going to do?
That doesn't set up a
very good relationship.
And some of you may
want to write this down,
but the key steps that we put in place
that really help her transform her
relationship was how about we start with,
hey, how's it going? Pretty normal. Right?
And that's actually something she does
with all her peers as well as the people
that she supervises.
It's a ten second interaction
where you can humanize yourself.
And in the second step that we did was
to also share what were the things that
were going well.
I cannot imagine that in your workspace
that only the sky is falling and you're
only having problems, right? There
are things that are going well,
but we often forget to mention the things
that are going well because it's not
urgent on our mind.
But it's still really important to mention
those amazing things that are going
on because doing so your supervisor
can know that you're actually
getting these things done.
And you're also reminding them like,
Hey,
I'm doing a really good job
here because we're busy.
And so if you don't remind them of that,
they're going to forget or they're not
going to be aware that you're doing that
good job. And then after you present
those positive things and say,
I think we should keep doing
these things because it's working,
then go into the challenges.
So what you've done there as you
set up a positive association.
So every time that you're going into
the office, he's not gonna be like,
let me duck and hide because all you're
coming to me with his problems. Right?
And here's the key thing. When you go
to your supervisor with challenges,
come up with a few solutions.
Maybe the solution is an I have the
answer that's going to fix all of this,
but at least have a here,
here's some two or three things that I
think we could research or here are some
people I think we can talk
to to help solve this.
So then what you do is you
change the association that the,
that your supervisor has
as you're the problem,
big crisis person to you're the person
who's going to come and share some good
news that I can also then share
with my supervisors as well.
Cause I love to share how while our
department's doing and how all my peoples
doing. Um, and if you
come to me with problems,
I know that you're also being very
proactive and like you over there,
you're somebody who's taking initiative,
right?
So you can see how your own biases
about what people are thinking about,
you can impact your interaction
with them and impact your career.
Uh,
now on the flip side,
what I want to then go into is why
does your personal brand matter?
Anybody know who that
is? Yeah, who's that?
I get a lot of laughters does everybody
know what a game of Thrones is? Oh,
it's only like half of the room.
I can't believe this unfathomable
to me that you don't know. Um, so,
uh,
I'm will,
I'm a Geek nerd and I love reading about
dragons and all these other things.
But just to give a high level overview
of game of Thrones is a book fantasy
series that has been
turned into an HBO series.
And this is one of my favorite characters.
Tyrian Lannister Tyrian is born into
this very powerful Lannister family,
which is fortunate and unfortunate.
Has father really hates
him and so does the sister,
but we won't get into her
on this particular story.
So Tyrian in the middle of the book
series finds himself in this really
interesting position where he's been
asked by his father to be the king's hand
and he has to to buys the king,
his nephew on strategies and how
to keep the country growing. Um,
and as many of you know who've
been following the series,
there's all these wars that are
breaking out everywhere, right?
Everybody is trying to be the key.
So teary and finds himself in his place
where kings landing has confronted
what's a battle and they are about
to lose this battle to the enemy.
But because Tyrian is
so smart and so witty,
he comes up with an ingenious plan and
with courage tries to fight to the death.
And what we find is that he actually
helps saves the country from being taken
over. So now you think,
oh, well if he's done that,
of course it's going to get
all these accolades, right? No,
what happens is his father,
because his father has this perception
that Tyrian is basically not reliable,
is you know, somebody
who drinks too much. Um,
and somebody gets under his skin and
is the cause of his wife's death.
And it has all these negative
associations about Tyrian.
What he does in fact as he actually
takes all the power away from Tyrian,
dismisses him and to add salt
to the wound, takes his lover.
I know it's very tragic, right? Um,
and this is what can happen if you're
not paying attention to your brand.
So we know how your own perception
of your association to your Brown,
how others perceive you might
impact your interaction. Now,
the other piece of your personal brand
is how other people actually see you.
And so if the person who is in charge
of your career getting the raises or
promotion or giving you projects,
or even if they're not,
but they're supposed to help you
as a colleague to get things done,
if they don't have a very
positive association with you,
no matter how hard you work,
no matter how long hours you put in,
no matter how great your accomplishments,
you could end up like Tyrian where you're
not going to be acknowledged or that
right? And that's a
tragedy. Um, because, uh,
obviously somebody who is saving the
country from being taken over by the enemy
should really get that accolade and we
don't want that to have happened to you,
but we see this time and time again.
How many of you can relate to that?
Where you're like,
why is that person getting a promotion
that I don't understand what they're
doing? A lot of head nods,
a lot of laughters there.
Okay, well we're like, ah,
you know,
I've been here until midnight every day.
Like everybody know that I'm alive. Like,
why? Why are you supplying stuff to me?
Right? Lots of hands that can
relate to that. And, and so that,
that's the reason why that one,
if somebody who is in charge or who
is there to collaborate with you,
if they don't have a
strong sense of your brand,
they're also not going to
be there to promote you. Um,
and so now you recognize how
important it is to have, um,
a strong personal brand and,
and to manage it because you can see
that it can impact your career. Um,
but why is there resistance to it?
There's often a resistance
to it because people, uh,
the most common response I get
is I don't want to be fake.
How many of you have that natural aversion
to like thinking about your brand?
I'm like, I don't want to
be faked some of you. Okay.
And what I would encourage you to do
is think about Oprah's lesson where she
says, I can be a much better Oprah
than I could be a pretend Barbara.
And the references is to this. When Oprah
started her career as an anchor woman,
the person she admired most with Barbara
Walters and what she would do it with
study Barbara and try to
mimic her when she's on TV.
And that was really exhausting.
And it wasn't until there was a moment
where she screwed something up and just
kind of laughed and let out a
sigh of relief that sh it hit her.
And there was a moment where their
light bulb went off and she said,
you know what? It's much better to
be me than to be a pretend Barbara.
And that was when her career took off.
So what I would encourage you to do
in thinking about your personal brand,
it's really not about making this where
you have to be fake or you have to kiss
up or you have to change yourself so
drastically so that you don't remember who
you are. Because that would be really
exhausting to wear a mask every day.
What I am encouraging you to do
is to take a look and say, hey,
what is going on with my personal
brown about my own assumptions and how?
How are other people really perceiving
me and is that something I'm happy with?
And if that's not,
what are some small things that I
can do to make some big changes? Um,
so, uh, you know,
I've worked with a lot of introverts
and people who are humble and shy.
How many of you relate to being
an introvert, humble or PSI?
Three floors to the room. Okay. Almost
every everybody in the room. Um,
and often when, when I talk to them
about this is there's this like,
I just feel like it's too
much or I just can't do it.
Right? Or like I just don't
want to change myself in,
in what I would encourage you to
do is to not make this huge leap.
I'm not asking you to go from this person
who is more shy or there have to being
like, Hey, I'm the life of the party,
but to really take some small steps that
can actually make a big impact on your
career. And here's an example of where
you can make that big difference.
So working with the client
where he's really bright,
he's really great at what he
does, but he's not. Um, uh,
but when you ask who he is
and the company, everybody's
kind of like who's that?
And it's because he's keeping himself
really small and really quiet.
And so some of the things that we did
for him to help him change his own
perception of himself,
but also to help others see that his
brand is something that is strong and
something that's positive that should
be associated with, um, is, uh,
to make some minor changes.
So for example,
when he goes to the cafeteria to get water
or goes to a meeting to just actually
say, hey, how's it going to
the person standing around him?
It's a little awkward at first, but
it's just that initial step, right?
Because everybody's feeling a little
awkward. Um, and so that's one thing.
So just by doing that,
he was actually able to get to know
people and people knew his name.
So that was an amazing feat for him.
So after a month of doing that and feeling
more competence cause he's like, Hey,
I didn't die from that. People
actually said hi back. It was amazing.
What we then did was say,
okay,
what can we do now to up your
game just a little bit more.
So his interaction with people
are, hey, how's it going?
Good. How's it going? Good.
Okay.
That was good as an initial step,
but it didn't really
allow room for rapport.
So the next thing that we added
to his assignment was to say,
what's one thing you can say about the
work that you're doing that you can share
with somebody else that you love?
Because when you're positive and excited
and being authentically sharing about
what you love,
it spreads joy to everybody.
So what we added to his assignment was
to come up with one thing every week that
he wanted to share. So the interaction
became, hey, how's it going? Good. Uh,
I've been working on this feature and
I'm super excited to hear the feedback on
it.
The reception to that was a lot more
positive and it actually opened the space
to have a longer conversation, which was,
oh, with the feature about Blah Blah,
blah,
you know?
And so it really allowed him to go more
into what he was doing and to share that
passion. And over time, by consistently
doing that, people in his company,
we're actually able to know his name and
also know what he brought to the table.
And more importantly,
have a positive association with him
because he was actually excited about the
work that he was doing as opposed to be
knowing, no, not the guy who, you know,
never talked to anybody who didn't care
and didn't seem like he was invested in
the company.
Can you see the big difference of that
small thing can make a lot of head nods?
Yes.
And so that's what we're hoping that you
can do today is to find the things that
are authentically true to you.
You know that you're excited about,
that you're happy about the things that
you're working on that are good and to
share it in a way that
honors your contributions.
But also uplifts everybody around you.
It doesn't have to be this experience,
that negative or that it's fake.
And by doing so,
the good thing about that is that
when there's an issue involving that
particular project or that
particular assignment,
the first person they might think about
calling to help solve that problem and
that issue comes up is you. And so what
we're doing is creating value for you,
but we're also creating value for
other team members and then overall
productivity for the organization.
So,
um, so now you know what a
personal brand is, right?
It's an immediate association that people
have about you and they think of you
are here of you,
similar to what we saw with Oprah.
You see the positive consequences that
can have in your career like the lawyer
that I was talking about or they're
really negative consequences.
It can have your career like my favorite
character Tyrian Lannister and you see
that you can be authentic in your own
way and still manage your personal brand.
Then the next question is, well,
what do you want to do with that?
What I find is that a lot of times
people go back and say, well,
I'm inspired for a day and I'm going to
do something and then kind of drop off.
What I would encourage you to do
is to be consistent about this.
So three things that I would recommend
that you do that can make a big change as
one, go back and do the
exercise we did earlier,
which is to think about the people that
you're interacting with on a regular
basis and ask yourself what do you think
they're thinking about you and how has
that impacted your interactions with them.
The second thing is actually go out
and ask a few coworkers about that.
What are the three key adjectives that
comes to mind when you think of me?
What do you think are my strengths and
what would you like to see more of?
This can be scary because you're being
vulnerable and putting it out yourself
out there,
but this is also moment,
a chance formation because without that
information it's really hard to assess
where you are and whether
you want to make changes.
And then the last piece is this.
With that information,
what are you going to do about it?
You got to go home and say,
we know what it's cool but I'm
not interested in making changes.
Or you can make that decision
to put things in your calendar.
And all it really takes is 15 minutes
a week to make these changes. Um,
so that you can better manage
your personal brand. Um,
and I know that with change it's
always scary even if it's good for you.
And it reminds me of a story of
myself when I was in college.
I was a long time ago and I was
in my senior year of college.
I got an interview with this tech company
that at the time was really up and
coming and I was so excited,
I was researching the company,
I was practicing my pitch.
I made a list of 10 questions so that I
wouldn't be stumped at the end. Right?
I like cross the t's and
dotted the i's and I was like,
I'm ready for this interview sound like
jotting into the interview. And I'm like,
oh, it's super excited. So the guy says
hi, and we kind of Chit Chat a little bit,
a little talk. He goes into, uh,
the spiel about his company. And
uh, over the next 15 minutes,
he answers every single question
that's on my list. And then he says,
what do you want to know about us?
I could not come up with anything.
I was completely stumped.
So the question I asked and I'm
still embarrassed about it, is,
is it true that your company
offers good free food?
You got the what that
company was Google. Yeah. Um,
and I was mortified. I, it stayed with
me for awhile. I'm like, oh my God,
they must think I'm in the
most awful interview ever.
And it's not a great question
and I've thought, you know, it,
it was embarrassing and it was
hard to actually share it out loud,
I guess share this story because I think
that that situation could have stayed
with me and derailed me and kept
me in a place where I'm like, oh,
I'm never going to talk
to Googlers ever again.
I'm never going to do anything here
again. Um, and fast forward years later,
I'm now being invited to come back and
give this presentation to you and to um,
how this honor of being able to share
through my own personal trials and
tribulations and through the training
that I've got and through the experiences
I've had and helping over a thousand
clients to now be able to give you these
strategies.
And I share that story because I can
assure you all of you have jobs at Google,
so you're definitely 10 steps ahead of me,
right?
Y'All at least got through the screening
around and got through the call backs
and I know the interview process here is
really long and you're way ahead of me
when I started. So if I can go from
that place to being where I am now,
I am more than confident that with
consistent work with these strategies that
you will be able to have a
really amazing successful career.
And that at this point,
if you make that choice to choose to
change your personal brand in a positive
direction,
you can definitely make that happen.
So it was with great honor to be here
and I just really wanted to humbly thank
you for spending this time together.
And I'll take questions after this.
Thank you.
So what about if your personal perception
of yourself and other coworkers are
different?
Hmm. So we've got depends.
Great question. So, um,
let's take a little bit into that.
Uh,
do you feel like your personal perception
of yourself as positive or negative?
A positive.
Okay.
And then do you think your coworkers
perception of you as positive,
negative or neutral?
Um,
still positive but just different stuff.
Okay.
Um,
and so what I would say with that is
it sounds like you're in a good place
because you were feeling
pretty good about yourself,
which is the first step and your coworkers
are feeling pretty good about you.
And so if what you want to do is to have
them see more of the stuff that you are
feeling good about, then the
recommendation would be, um, you know,
depending on the interactions you have
with people to discuss those things more
to find ways and highlighting
those things more.
So give me a specific example cause like
it's harder to answer in the abstract.
Um, what the positive
association of yourself that
you want others to know about
you. Um, taking more
iterative. Okay. Okay.
So if you want to show
that you're somebody who is
taking more initiative, um,
uh, one of the ways you can do that
is if you're at a team meeting, um,
instead of just sitting quiet
and not saying that to you,
but for the sake of time, what I would say
is that, you know, at every meeting, um,
you should at least make one comment
if you're not making a comment, right?
And asking questions.
And the other thing that you can do to
really show initiative is if there's
something that's being assigned
or things that are, um,
projects that are coming up,
you,
you would be the person who would
volunteer for it. Um, and that's,
that's showing initiative right there.
The key thing then though is to follow
up that and when you're working on these
projects to let people on your team and
let your supervisors know that as well.
So there is a one school of thought where
they say you keep doing the good work
and things will fall in place.
And now there's this concept of personal
branding there you have to proactively
influence or change the perception
of other people you see any conflict?
No, I don't, I doubt at all.
And I think that's a really
great question. I think, um,
um, the basis is you have to
do good work. You know, um,
if you're doing bad work and
you're expecting everybody
else to think good about
you,
that's a really hard place to be.
And that would not be something that I
would advocate for any client cause I,
I'm really about having integrity,
honesty, and authenticity.
So you do need to do consistent good work,
um,
and some things will fall into place.
Um, so you know, you get a job at Google,
that's things falling into place and
Google is an amazing place to work.
Now if you want to elevate yourself
and get to that next stage where you're
going into management and leadership,
um,
there has to be some
changes in your strategies.
So the foundation of doing good work,
it's still a core foundation
of who you are, but,
but that extra step of sharing the
good work that you're doing, um,
doesn't take away from that. And it
only adds to that. Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Bye.
Yeah.